carlos hernandez the kansas city royals
pitcher
100 mile an hour fastball are
approaching it
third major league start today what do
you think of that glove
he's sporting
the one two grounded and that's gonna
find a hole
harold castro will score nico goodram
has himself a first inning rbi and
detroit has drawn first blood here in
kansas city
hangar nico got on top and finds a hole
look at him kept those hands they did
get the barrel in it
absolutely you want to play
romine drives one to center back goes
edward oliveira's and he'll watch it
clang off the wall
one run is home nico goodroom trying to
score and he does head first slide to
make it three nothing thanks to the two
run double from austin romine yeah
tigers are loving that heater right now
paul's not up in the zone just kind of
mid-up that's a hanging slider right
there boom hit me hit me and he did
malaveras can't get to it
plays it pretty well they have a good
turn and nico beats it
and now he is behind derek hill two
balls and one strike
and that's grounded into left field hill
gets his first hit and he's trying for
his first rbi but
not
tonight
as it's been going back to 2011
a base runner challenges alex gordon and
he guns him down with salvador perez on
the other end
oh
this was classic how about dad oh man
missed him the first time around romine
he's out
let's see what he can do with
adelberto mondesi
hits it deep to left field
he has eight consecutive hits
and this one is a home run he is
unstoppable
you know
he's just so his hands are so gifted
this is a very handsy tansy type swing
you know it was right there in the
middle and it was perfect form head
position there great balance in the
swing with his lower half
and he touched them all
with his fifth
so it's 3-1
it's not good to run
if you're
daz put the left-handed batter up
strokes one to center and that's a base
hit on a one-two pitch willie castro
comes through and gets the tigers run
right back here in the second he
restores the three-run lead
went down and got it look at this look
at how he stays on that ball
did not pull off at all realize he had
to stay through it
it's good hitting man it really is
so he has hits
in his last eight at bats
he has reached in his last nine plate
appearances
if you add in the walk
and there is a base hit up the left
field line and
down into the corner
and here we go again with the cycle
watch for adelberto mondaci
he has a home run and a double in the
first three innings
and now the royals trail by two
he got fooled badly on a first breaking
ball pitch then he tried to sneak a
cheap piece of cheese by him 91 and
that's in off the plate not even close
to being a strike but it doesn't have to
be when you're hot
you swing that back you're gonna make
some contact that's how it is
there's a base hit into right field for
franco
mondece comes around to score
that is rbi number 38 for franco to lead
the royals
and he has
an rbi or at least
a pace for an rbi per game over his last
18. yeah you know this is what premium
rbi guys do
they find a way to knock that run in
that's a ball that a lot of guys would
try to pull and hit out of the park
especially in this season it is the
short like that want to put up numbers
but he sees there's one guy over there
and he's going to pick up that run and
the royals continue to pressure and
climb back into this one
whit started to go now he stops so no
hit for monday but he gets a walk
and now he's the fourth royal ever
to reach in 11 straight plate
appearances
joining amos otis steve braun
and joe randa
joe's gonna have to deal with him big
matchup here against alberto monteci the
2-2
he struck him out these are the best
three sliders in a row i've seen joe
throw what a time to retire monday for
the first time in the series
good death on all these slides look at
it go down
we know he'll get next time get some
sliders
last
last year heath had 60 stolen bases
most by a royals farmhand since terence
gore in 2013.
and he's on the move
got him and they got him what a throw by
eric haas and a great tag
by nico goodrum
they cut him down and there's one away
boy eric really came out of there
got rid of it quickly
good pick good tag
it's a poor slide
tigers took advantage of it
this is not easy
down right on the blade
another o2
on the ground of short
the five-game losing streak is over
tigers turned the tables on the royals
this time
it's detroit winning the one run game
4-3 the final